I think that it's wonderful that you've
been on this awesome show that does so
well and we've watched you for many
years I mean Hello Ross's girlfriend
that was you know another Ross and Joey
I was very
really found the friends got around all
the friends and funny enough we uh we
hung out for friendsgiving the last time
you were here well speaking of friends
who was more fun Ross or Joey I will say
this they were all incredibly kind to me
and I'm friends with them to this day
especially Lisa Couture and I've gotten
very close they're really lovely people
but I love telling this story but on the
very first you know you taped live in
front of an audience like this and and
then you go and you do like a like a
kind of a curtain called then you bow to
the audience and um Matthew Perry came
over to me and he just goes like you
know get ready for your life to change
and it did the show really changed my
life it was a great experience for me
back then
um to this day I'm traveling I'm like
eight-year-olds or like black girl from
Friends black girl from Friends
[Applause]